commis firing has Democrats demanding
that a special prosecutor investigated
any links between the Trump campaign and
Russia President Trump calls the
Democrats response a disgrace he posted
a video on Twitter showing how they also
wanted Comey to go I think it would not
be a bad thing for the American people
if he did stuff down and finally believe
that Jim Comey should resign Senator
Reid of course did you want to see him
gone so it's absolutely true the
Democrats have been very critical of
James Comey and many of us did call for
his resignation now the Democrats insist
there are too many unanswered questions
about the firing Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill where commis replacement
will appear in just a few hours Nancy
good morning good morning his name is
Andrew McCabe he's now the acting FBI
director and he's going to be testifying
here in a few hours before the Senate
Intelligence Committee in commis place
now the official title of this
long-planned hearing is worldwide
threats but senators are inevitably
going to want to talk about commis
removal which has become a partisan
flashpoint director Comey kind of became
an issue himself and so it's obviously
within the president's authority and
role to do this Republican leaders are
standing by the president's move so we
have now mr. president our Democratic
colleagues complaining about the removal
of an FBI director whom they themselves
repeatedly and sharply criticized in the
face of a deafening drumbeat from
Democrats is time for a special
prosecutor special prosecutor a special
prosecutor Republicans can call for a
special prosecutor to be appointed that
will not be able to be fired by this
president Democrats argue everything
about commis firing was unorthodox from
the way he was informed the president's
one-page letter was completely bizarre
to the timing you can't fire the
investigator when he is investigating
here
administration they found an ally in the
Senate's Republican chairman of the
Intelligence Committee the timing and
the reasons for this decision did made
little sense to me and I don't think
I've heard anything since last night
that would clarify that anyway but
Richard Burr ANSYS a special prosecutor
would only get in the way of the
investigation he's already conducting he
and his Democratic counterpart have
asked call me to meet with their
committee next week in closed session I
think Jim Comey oughta have is if not
his day in court at least his day on the
hill to be able to lay out his his side
of the case before this hearing this
morning the Senate Intelligence
Committee announced that it had issued
its first subpoena for documents
belonging to the fired NSA Michael Flynn
these are documents that he has refused
to hand over and some members of this
committee Norah even joked that perhaps
the newly fired James Comey might make a
great investigator for this committee as
it continues its work looking into the
Russian connection all right we'll see
about that Nancy thank you so much